if you want people to vote for you you
might not want to say that their state
is a disgrace a complete and total
softball Trump interview went horribly
wrong were Trump called Nevada
disgraceful when he was asked about hey
you lost twice what's your plan to win
in 2024. this is so endlessly
fascinating Trump was interviewed by the
uh this is called the Nevada Globe okay
the Nevada Globe the globe interview of
President Donald Trump I encourage you
to look at all of this the picture of
trump sitting there on a podcast
interview while they were with him is
really really wild stuff it's a lot this
is a transcript okay this is a text
interview there's a fascinating section
I want to focus in on the interviewers
say to Trump so let's talk Nevada
Governor Lombardo lost Clark County by
six points he lost Washoe County by two
points yet he's still won the
governorship additionally he's recently
signed legislation that Awards 25
million dollars to The Culinary Union
the Nevada Republican party believes
that that money is going to be used for
ballot harvesting proponents claim it's
going to be used for a capital
Improvement project that hasn't been
identified a Republican presidential
candidate hasn't won Nevada since 2004
you lost Nevada twice how do you win
Nevada
look at Trump's answer
I think I won the last time I think I
won both times by a lot this is a state
that is disgraceful
listen you lost twice here how are you
going to turn it around how are you
going to win this state is an absolute
disgrace vote for this man right away I
mean just not even passing the sniff
test for what is going to help him and
Trump goes on to say you know we sued on
the basis of they robbed the vote at a
level we had a lawsuit that was so good
and the judge didn't want to see it he
didn't even want to see it we had a
lawsuit that was in my opinion
conclusive but you know we have guys
like laxalt lack salt was a very weak
candidate he was pathetic you know I
helped laxalt do the best he could I
guess his grandfather was strong his
father was good but I guess the chain
got weaker and weaker remember the
question was how are you going to win
Nevada after losing it twice Trump's
talking about nonsense
um but Adam laxalt is a stiff and he
didn't do the job he was a lawyer he was
working for a lot of different people on
trying to do the vote thing but he
wasn't the right guy when you see
Trump's words as a transcript they are
10 times nuttier and more meaningless
Trump going on we have great people
working now we have great lawyers
working they used covid to cheat the
last time they used covid to cheat but
we think we have a great team in place
to stop it we are then asked to wrap the
interview
um okay and then they they go on to talk
talk to Trump a little bit more
um this it's beyond parody really it's
be when he's asked about the fact that
he lost and how will you win he insists
I actually won I actually love the
transcript of the Trump interview I
think it's a great thing because it
really makes it for people who read
right who know how to read it makes the
statements even more meaningless where
he just sort of trails off and skips
around from one topic to another so
Trump's strategy to win Nevada is going
to be
um it is
calling the state a disgrace insisting
he actually won even though he lost
and I guess saying that they're gonna
fix it by something related to ballot
harvesting not a winning strategy in
Nevada my bets on Joe Biden and Nevada
if if I'm totally honest with you but we
hope we will have to wait and see when
you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below